welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and a deeper power in the Star Wars
universe beyond thrawn beyond night
sister magic beyond the basic binary
Dark Side is coming in these
final episodes of Ahsoka with X Jedi
balen skull since seen something calling
to him on the magical graveyard of
paridia something calls to me can't you
hear it something
stirs here can't you see it something
else stirs the whole point of traveling
the pathway to paridia from the main
Star Wars galaxy to another one was to
see what was stirring at the end of that
path and that something was definitely
Grand Admiral thrawn and his terrifying
Legion of red banded Stormtroopers along
with a trio of witches named after the
fates of Greek mythology honestly we're
good with that it's all creepy enough
Halloween 2023 costumes for days but no
balance skull and shinhati CK power that
thrawn cannot give them a power that
even the night sisters seem to be
getting the hell out of Dodge from and
in this video I'm gonna break down what
that could possibly be what the biggest
power of the Star Wars Universe actually
is in summary I think there are really
three possible likely options from Star
Wars lore that it might be at this point
in Star Wars history bendu the gods of
mortis or the priestesses or Priestess
from the Wellspring of Life all three of
these come from Rebels and Clone Wars
and since I'm pretty sure two-thirds of
you didn't actually watch those shows
and no shame by the way that's what new
rockstars is for I'm gonna dig into all
three of these options but if you are
curious to learn more about rebels in
particular we did a four-part Rebels
recap series that sufficiently catches
you up on the big stuff okay let's
re-examine the transcript of what
exactly balen said in this episode when
they approached paridia Balin recalls
that the Jedi archives spoke of this
place it was the end of the migration
route used by the star whales as they
Traverse the void from one galaxy to the
other and then he calls pridia a
graveyard back in episode 2 Bayland
suggested that the path to peridia was a
fairy tale Legend shared among the
children in the Jedi Temple and now with
shinhati hiko's full Shakespearean and
says this is a land of dreams and
Madness
children's stories come to life he goes
on stories of this galaxy are considered
folk tales
some ancient past
long forgotten and balen begins to tease
that the power thrawn promises is just
the latest in the cycle of the Jedi
versus the Empire and that balen is
seeking something beyond that that sort
of power is fleeting what I seek
so I may finally bring this cycle to an
end sin asks if that new beginning is
here on paridia and balen says if the
old stories are true now later in the
episode Baylin goes into more detail
about this deeper power when he talks
about his disillusionment from the Jedi
Order there was no future there hey you
clearly see one here
in this Wasteland Balon answers that the
great mothers being here indicates that
the importance of pretty as the location
the former great witch Kingdom of the
death of Mary but Shin says they seem
eager to leave this place
maybe we should too perhaps they flee a
power
greater than their own something calls
to me can't you hear it something stirs
here can't you see it okay so that
narrows down our possible suspects we
are looking for one a power beyond the
fleeting political slash military
strength of thrawn two a power beyond
the Jedi Order three a power of the
night sisters fear and four a power
beyond the known Galaxy of Star Wars
something that you would have to cross
the void to access so we're not talking
about snoke or the first order as those
are really on the political scale that
bailin is uninterested in thrawn
offering them and we're not talking
about Palpatine or the dark side or the
Sith Eternal as those are on the scale
of the Jedi and the night sisters just
another class of force wielders who are
part of that same cycle discoverable
within the known Galaxy also we should
note that Balin says something stirs and
it just sounds like he senses something
animalistic in quality and while that
could be loath wolves paridia already
has a native canine species of howlers
and I just don't think we would see
howlers if there were also going to be
loath wolves on paridia now there's a
really cool Fitness brand kind of fit
kind of fat we are big fans of theirs
they're big fans of what we do at new
rockstars they do a lot of really fun
pop culture inspired fitness clothing
and we collaborated with them on this
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtle shirt that
I'm wearing kind of fit kind of fat is
for those who love Fitness food and
everything in between they're messages
that everybody is worthy of being
respected and deserving of equal
opportunities and representation bodies
from all walks of life types shapes
colors and abilities should be
celebrated few pop culture icons put
Fitness and food together as well as the
Ninja Turtles like half their whole deal
is that they love pizza arguably more
than half kind of fit kind of fats
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtle shirt is
full of fitness and food Easter eggs
from The chawabunga Branding on the
pizza to the weight plate on the front
of the van two forks replacing raft size
but you can only get this team and
t-shirt at kind of fit kindafat.com
there's a limited Supply so grab one
today and while you're there check out
all of their other cool products the
link for the shirt is also in this
video's description so I think the
likeliest suspect is bendu what or who
it's been do bendu is a large large
mysterious force-wielding creature that
Kanan Jairus and Ezra Bridger discover
on the planet etelon and Rebels season
3. he's voiced by Tom Baker the fourth
doctor of Doctor Who sharing that Legacy
with who Yang voice actor David Tennant
bendu derives his name from George
Lucas's original name for the Jedi Jedi
bendu and that name was repurposed to
the canonical precursors to the Jedi
Order that died been do throughout
Rebels season 3 bendu serves as a
spiritual mentor to Kanan and Ezra
guiding Kanan through his recent
blindness from Maul in the season 2
finale and helping Ezra deal with his
mystical connection to Maul via that
Sith holocron but Bindu is not purely on
the light side of the force as a
practitioner the force sees a true
agnostic and he's totally okay with Ezra
and Maul working together and in the
season 3 finale when Kanan goes to him
for help against thrawn he's initially
reluctant until Kanan insults his power
and then bendu appears as a big old
Mufasa face and the storm clouds and
fires lightning at thrawn's Ground
Forces and catches some Rebel White
Wings in that Crossfire he doesn't care
he's got some mad old man get off my
lawn energy thrawn blast him to
submission but bendu cryptically
foretells thrawn's bait with a pergoal
in the season 4 finale before laughing
and fading back into the force I see you
like many arms surrounding you in a cold
Embrace so with Ron back in the series
balance seeking a mystical power beyond
the Jedi and the Sith Bindu is just a
perfect option atalon is a similar
Wasteland Planet like paridia is and the
way those goofy no tea appear as first
as rocks is very similar to the way
bendu camouflages himself at first on
atalon Balin uses the term something
stirs it just kind of has the vibe of
bendu stirring and Tom Baker doing the
voice just fits so well with Doctor Who
David Tennant being the Storyteller of
this episode who says the big line a
long time ago
in a galaxy far far away it'd be one
doctor connecting to another bindu's
Powers we think do come from a place
beyond what the night sisters possess
his name is bendu which has deep ties to
the origins of the Jedi though not
specific to the Jedi and the great
mothers hate the Jedi and regard them
with a feral stink it reeks a Jedi
and I think the animal they're really
smelling here could be bendu but the
second suspect are the mortise Gods whom
I've talked about a lot in recent videos
they come from the Clone Wars season 3
Arc they're kind of the three Gods the
Holy Trinity of the Star Wars Universe
they live in the realm of mortis that
Ahsoka Obi-Wan and Anakin visit the
mortise gods are designated as Star Wars
celestials and they are believed to come
from another galaxy and I would imagine
they're more powerful than the Knight
sisters are the daughter lives on an
Ahsoka and I like the interpretation
that the father could live on in
Anakin's ghost so yes we should include
the more disguise as possible suspects
but let's talk about the Wellspring of
life priestesses this comes up in Clone
Wars season six when the voice of
Qui-Gon guides Yoda to the epicenter of
the cosmic force in this galaxy the
Wellspring of life where midichlorians
are created here Yoda encounters five
priestesses who each represent a
different emotion Serenity Joy anger
confusion and sadness they put Yoda
through a series of trials with his
shadow self and Yoda ends up in a kind
of conflict with Sidious and Dooku and
then sees the priestess's true face when
asked about this in a q a they filoni
explained that his actual idea for the
five princesses were that they were
going to be one entity the way that I
reconciled what that being is is
actually one being it's one ancient
beings separated over time that for our
perception to be able to see her she is
these many different iconic things
presented to us but she died a long long
long long long time ago she is conscious
in the force and she has a limited
ability to manifest I am wondering if
the way the great mothers all speak
collectively with multiple voices
layered together could be connected to
that concept like think about it the
witches of daphomir the Knight sisters
the death of Mary could derive their
sorcery and their ancient lineage from
being one dimension of those Wellspring
priestesses cast out from the others
banished to a Galaxy without
midichlorians perhaps a Galaxy and a
planet doomed to die out and be a
wasteland graveyard where Pergo go to
die so I leave the question to you who
or what is Balin hearing and really what
do you think is the ultimate power of
the star first Universe something that
can give bailin a new beginning
untethered to the Light Side versus Dark
Side Wars of the past I think Bindu is
the best option of the three but I want
to hear your thoughts please support our
Channel by grabbing an Ahsoka inspired
welcome shirt available at nerd Riot
that shop and be sure to subscribe to
the break room for episodes of WikiLeaks
or Ahsoka after show subscribe to all
three channels of the new rockstars
Network you can follow me at eavos
follow new rockstars thanks for watching
I'll see you next time bye
[Music]
thank you